thank you very much my name is Miko
hoopin and I'm the chief research
officer
called f-secure I'm based in Helsinki
Finland which of course you might best
know as the home city of the Linux
kernel which is where it was born 27
years ago but I've spent the last 24
years myself reverse engineering malware
and tracking online criminals that's
what I've been doing since 1991 and it's
been a pretty wild ride for 24 years
work in security especially work with
malware and viruses and Trojans and
backdoors because things have changed
over and over again
the very first PC virus was written in
1986 it's a virus which really not know
as brain dot a and actually used to
carry a copy of brain virus with me
which was on a five and a quarter inch
floppy disk I don't do it anymore
because three years ago I actually took
the trip to Pakistan to find the
original authors of the brain dot a
virus which I did and I actually spoke
with these guys to nowadays businessmen
who work in Lahore and nobody's run an
ISP in an internet operator never the
guys who wrote the very first PC virus
in 1986 and we had a very interesting
chat about the birth of this whole
problem and how it came to be it was
quite clear that they didn't really
understand what they started they
definitely didn't want to start you know
all these problems that we have today
they were basically just toying around
with the idea of writing a
self-replicating code and they did and
when I was leaving Lahore actually gave
my copy of brain to the original order
so I have it no more it's it's back to
where it came from but from 1986 to 2014
the shift in in the people behind the
malware could not have been bigger
originally was just happy hackers
typically teenage boys running viruses
and their motive was that they had no
motive there was no reason why they were
writing viruses they've been writing
viruses which were typically destructive
on Friday the 13th they would override
hard drives and former disks or display
stupid messages and the people behind
them Albert gained nothing they made no
money with their malware they got no
fame for it just basically breaking the
law for no good reason
nevertheless that was the main problem
we had for for quite a while and I
actually think that the year 2003 is
when the biggest amount of changes
happened in the world of malware before
2003 basically all the malware we were
finding were just hobbyists in 2003 well
first of all we had a series of some of
the largest malware outbreaks in history
email worms and web worms you remember
things like malice or love letter aka I
love you virus which were going around
in 2001 and 2002 but then in 2003 there
was a series of automatically
replicating Windows worms which would
infect your Windows servers and your
Windows workstations automatically you
as a user didn't have to do anything at
all they were using remote exploits in
Windows Services and at the time in 2003
nobody was running a firewall so all the
windows boxes were sitting online with
public IP addresses and no firewall
whatsoever ports open
which looking at it from now seems
ridiculous but that's where we were in
2003 so slammer Sasser
blaster and series of other worms went
around and scanned every single ipv4
address infecting every single Windows
computer which was online and which
hadn't been patched against the
particular problems and patching was
problematic at the time because we had
no Windows Update so people would
actually go manually and download
binaries from Microsoft comm to patch
their windows systems so things were
pretty bad and that became the turning
point the problems became so bad for
Microsoft that they simply had to do
something and they did Bill Gates
since the famous trustworthy computing
memo to all employees of Microsoft and
they really started turning around their
security processes and now looking at it
over a decade later well that's exactly
what they did
Microsoft used to be the worst example
of workstation security nowadays they're
one of the best examples in how to do
security correctly in fact if you take
let's say 64-bit Windows 8.1 and compare
its security architecture to pretty much
anything else out there on the market
it's it's excellent they've really
changed things around
of course they still get targeted a lot
because they are the biggest target on
computer side but it's not just
computers that we use nowadays tablets
smartphones of course they have become
another new target and if you look at
the Microsoft platforms they actually
are not being targeted on for example or
phone on the phones I don't smartphone
side they're actually Linux based
devices our target number one
and when I say Linux based devices I
mean Android because Android is the
Linux distribution and this is
interesting because of course when you
have Linux workstations and servers
computers they don't really have them of
a problem at all
Windows does but then when you go to the
smartphone world it's exactly the other
way around
Windows doesn't have a malware problem
line-ups does or Android does which is
surprising but then again it's exactly
the same thing with the market search
Android is number one on smartphones
Windows is number one in computers
attackers go after the large low-hanging
fruit so in 2003 Microsoft started to
turn around something else happened in
2003 as well we found the very first
money-making malware the first attacks
from attackers who actually had a motive
to do what they were doing who actually
wanted to steal or want you to earn
money somehow else I mean the very first
examples of money making with malware
were basically cooperations of email
spammers with Malabo of Reuters spammers
needed botnets or large amount of
infected computers so they could use
them to
doubt spam and of course Marvel writers
had those computers to do it and they
started cooperating around 2003
that's when spam problem shifted from
being something that was done from
rented servers to something which was
done from botnets from him user
computers so money entered the picture
and very quickly after that the
old-school hobbyist malware writers
disappeared they either stopped or they
switched into the money-making part of
the of the scene and it was also a third
major shift during the same year in 2003
was the first time that I was analyzing
a piece of malware in our labs and
f-secure which we eventually deducted
that this has to be something which was
written by a government this isn't done
by hobbyist in 2003 the case in
particular was a targeted attack sent to
a European defense contractor company
and they send us a sample and at the
time this was still the time of email
worms so we would regularly get sample
submissions from our customers who were
running our random virus on their on
their companies but almost always
practically every single time winner
when we got a new sample we would get
the very same sample within half an hour
or within 15 minutes from a dozen of
other companies because these were
outbreaks like something started
spreading over email and it very quickly
went global but in this particular case
we got a sample submission from our
customer they had sent samples to us
numerous times before but now we didn't
get further samples it was the only
sample we got it one sample from one
customer which was unusual what was even
more unusual was that the sample wasn't
a binary was a Window System but he
wasn't an exe he was a Word document
which actually contained an exploit and
that was unusual so I spoke with the
customer like how did you get this this
malware into your systems and the
customer said there's actually unusual
how we got it we got it in an email
which was sent to one of our employees a
high-ranking executive and it was
sent by one of our clients and when we
spoke with the client they actually
never sent the email it was spoofed
email and when you click to open the
word document the exploit ran infected
the system with a backdoor which gave an
outside party full access to the
computer and then displayed a real word
document on screen as as a miss
direction to make make the user feel at
ease he clicks on the document he gets a
document on the screen and these exactly
the same is exactly the same method that
we still today in 2015 see in apt
attacks or targeted attacks and that
particular attack came from China and we
are still seeing attacks coming from
China today which use exactly the same
method targeted attacks where the target
doesn't get infected by chance it's not
random the target has been chosen before
no one else gets infected and the
modeler in question is tailor-made for
the target please well we believe it
came from a government and one of the
reasons why governments intelligence
agencies and militaries like using
cyberattacks if you will or or online
attacks is that they get deniability
it's very very hard to prove this
conclusively however in that particular
case we saw the very same servers that
the information was being sent to the
very same binary structures multiple
multiple times over the over over
several years and looking at who was
getting hit with these attacks it's
quite easy to detect a mr. Chinese but
it also ended up in in a sort of
plainness after we saw so many targeted
attacks and they were always coming from
China eventually after a couple of years
we started seeing China everywhere and
you know it was pretty automatic to
assume that here's yet another apt
attack targeting a European or American
defense contractor or government entity
it's the Chinese until eventually we
realize that not all not all of these
are Chinese there's also Russian Kasey's
and so on and so
to China of course China has been
targeted with the tax themselves from
foreign governments as cell as
well.these has this has of course
happened as well nevertheless from that
crucial year from 2003 the game has
changed hobbyists have disappeared all
the money-making which is being done is
nowaday being done by organised online
crime gangs an online crime gangs sound
very virtual I mean what does it
actually mean so let's look at some of
the examples of people who have been
involved in money-making with malware
most cases we were never able to track
down the individuals behind the attacks
sometimes we are able to do it sometimes
they even get taken into courts and
uncharged
for example this car here is Vladimir
touching a russian Estonian living in
the city of Tartu who was running an
operation which made something in the
range of 12 million dollars by spoofing
DNS servers to use that to redirect
traffic and he's under custody right now
waiting extradition to the United States
actually but the mechanisms that online
criminals started to use to make money
started shifting from the early days
where it was just spam then we started
seeing key loggers so your system gets
infected key logger starts recording
everything you type and they collect
your passwords or even more importantly
your credit card information which you
type in every time you buy something
online it will be typing in your name
your address your credit card
information your security code and
that's how they collect it and then we
started seeing banking Trojans as online
banking became more and more common
banking Trojans started exploiting money
transfers online and the interesting
thing about banking Trojans is that
banking Trojans practically never target
the bank's old systems because the
bank's own systems are typically very
well protected
instead they target banks customers
sisters that's the easy
that's the soft target and of course
there's much less money to be stolen
from the accounts of individual users
but they're much much easier to catch
much much easier to infect so if you
want to make 1 million dollars with
banking Trojans you can either try to
hack into the bank which is very hard
and steal 1 million dollars or you hack
1,000 home computers running Windows XP
service pack 1 and you steal $1,000 from
each and you get your million and that's
what they're doing so the mechanism is
banking Trojans practically always use
is that the end user first gets infected
through email attachments or through web
exploit kits and once they're infected
with the banking Trojan the Trojans do
nothing nothing at all they just simply
sit and wait until one day the user
himself decides to go online to do some
online banking for example to pay his
bills and that's when the Trojans
activate they typically change account
numbers on the fly or insert extra
transactions so you go online to pay 3
bills and you end up paying 4 bills and
you never saw the fourth one and this is
the reason why banks were eventually
forced into adding extra checks into
their own line banking systems checks
like we see it today what you know
tokens or text message authentication
the problem that they're trying to solve
is the problem of banking Trojans and
this becomes a game of cat and mouse we
quickly started seeing banking Trojans
which infected not just your computer
but when you use your computer for
example to charge your phone with the
USB cable it would also infect your
fault typically your Android device
which then means when you do banking
transactions on your computer and the
bank sends you a text message it sends
it you're infected Android handset which
will authenticate on your behalf and you
still lose the money even though there
are extra checks built into these
systems then we started seeing other
ways of making money one technique which
we started seeing two years ago which I
find especially interesting is Bitcoin
mining or currency mining mining for
virtual currencies nowadays they
actually don't mind for bitcoins at all
because it's way too hard but they might
mind for alternative currencies like
light coin or name coin or doki corn or
whatever and then once they've created
virtual
currencies with bad taste converted to
bitcoins than they convert it to dollars
or actually typically to roubles but
nevertheless and that's interesting
because they're the theft isn't
targeting the user it's targeting the
computer itself the valuable thing isn't
the user or what the user has the
valuable thing is the computing power of
the device but the biggest headache
we've had for the last two years has
been ransom Trojans so Trojans which
will lock your system and demand a
payment from the victim in order to get
your system back some of these just lock
the system some of them actually encrypt
your files some of them claim to be a
copyright agency which are locked your
system because you had unlicensed mp3
music files on your hard drive and you
have to pay a fee something claimed to
be the police some of them go as far as
claim that your system has been locked
by the authorities because there's
illegal poor typically child porn or
child abuse images on your hard drive
and they are actually right because
these dos Trojans actually do drop real
child abuse images on your hard drive
which is something which we call a dick
move it's really
they basically incriminate you because
now you have in legally missing images
on your hard drive and it's it's pretty
pretty rough these ransom Trojans
practically always work what I mean by
that is that if you pay the ransom you
will get your files back and if it's an
encrypting trojan like CDP locker or
crypto wall or crypto defense or
cryptolocker the encryption they use the
duty to encrypt your files is strong
enough typically RSA 2048 and they've
implemented it correctly there's no back
doors there's no other way to get your
files back if you don't have backups the
only way to get your files back is to
pay and the payment of course is done
with Bitcoin
some of these guys actually go to great
lengths to make sure you're able to
bathe a there's even one group which
runs a support forum for their customers
aka their victims
in through which they will help I mean
if you can't figure out how to convert
dollars the bitcoins they will help you
if you can't figure out how to use the
decryption program to get your files
back they will actually help you and the
reason why they actually deliver and why
they actually help their victims is that
these guys need a reputation they need
to have a good reputation because they
know that every single victim won't I
mean nobody pays this ransom before
first trying to find an alternative
solution everybody will Google for a
solution and they will find that other
victims couldn't find any other way out
and they paid and they did get their
files back so they they know it works
and then they will pay as well now of
course we never recommend to pay ransom
for for to these clowns
maybe this case that's two weeks ago
yeah police station here in United
States got infected and they didn't have
backups and they needed their files back
because the problem is it's not just
encrypting one laptop its encrypting
every single drive it can mount so in a
networked environment it goes through
your whole network and encrypts
everything if your cloud storage is
multiple as a drive it's gonna encrypt
your cloud storage as well and if you
have your backups in your cloud they're
gone as well so it's a problem so here
the cops had to pay the criminals to get
their files back which is a little bit
weird now these ransom Trojans have
already moved from computer platforms to
smartphones and smart televisions that's
an Android phone looked by the Raritan
Trojan and that's a an LG smart
television looked by the brow lock
Trojan which tells the story of you
haven't pinned you haven't paid your TV
tax and now if you want to continue
using your system you have to pay a fine
and it's localized into twelve different
languages what you see here is it's if
well that's what it looks like when you
get infected in Finland it's the Finnish
police who has locked your television
and of course it's not the finished
police
but that's already getting closer to the
much-hyped internet-of-things
right that's a smart TV that's not a
computer that's a smart TV and it's
locked by malware well the Internet of
Things of course is not something which
is in the future it's very much already
here today and there's quite a bit of
hype around the risks of the Internet of
Things but most of the risk scenarios
you hear about make no sense people hear
scary stories about how evil hackers
will hack into your house and somehow
hack your connected devices like your
toaster and they will turn your toaster
into 11 and they will burn your house
down because they are evil hackers or
they will hack you a car and then
disable your breaks and then they will
drive you off a cliff and they will kill
you and scenarios like these make no
sense whatsoever like why why would they
do that what's in it for them I mean
hackers are not interested in killing
random people it's just not logical they
are interested in attacks where they
benefit somehow so if we can come up
with scenarios where the attackers can
actually somehow benefit from hacking
connected devices then those attacks are
much more likely to happen so for
example your car is not gonna be hacked
by someone who wants to disable your
brakes it might be hacked by someone who
wants to open the doors and start the
engine and drive away steal your car you
know stealing car see the cars it's a
good business to be and it's already a
big big problem so if they could do it
easier with hacking of course that's
interesting but we could easily combine
the previous problem we were talking
about with Internet of Things as well
so how about your car gets infected and
then when you get into your car to drive
away it's locked by a ransom Trojan and
you have to pay money if you want to
store your engine we actually haven't
seen this this hasn't happened yet but
it's easy to see that it could happen
and this would make much more sense than
many of the other scenarios for Internet
of Things or maybe your SmartWatch gets
locked by a ransom Trojan and can't use
it until you pay and by the way this
watch I saw this a month ago at the
Mobile World Congress in Barcelona
nicest SmartWatch I've seen one made by
Huawei Huawei watch pretty nice device
actually has a quad-core processor and
512 mix of RAM in a watch which is
remarkable I don't know how how hot it
gets in you on your wrist but it's and
it looks pretty nice so in terms of
things yeah sure there will be attacks
against connected devices but they
probably are not gonna be like the
attacks that the headlines are talking
about so what about then the
governmental attacks criminals are
obvious problem criminals are actually
the biggest problem still today by far
if you cannot get hit by something it's
gonna be most likely a crime gang most
likely coming from Russia or Ukraine or
Belarus or Romania or Moldova or maybe
China or maybe Brazil but it's gonna be
criminals who want to make money that's
by far the most common problem to get
infected by some hobbyist malware is
rare to be attacked by a hacktivist gang
like you know anonymous well it happens
but typically you've done something
first which causes the attack because
most of the attacks done by activist
gangs or activist movements are revenge
ease or something or retaliation over
some wrong day they won't want to write
but getting infected by governmental
malware is very rare you have to be
someone special to be targeted by this
you have to be interesting enough to be
targeted by a foreign government so
basically if you weren't targeted by
real-world spies before the internet
came around then you probably aren't
gonna be targeted by governments or
targeted attacks either and do you know
this that this is different from
surveillance I mean
surveillance online surveillance of
course covers or targets everybody know
it's a very democratic it's it's
interested in everybody's communication
but targeted attacks are targeted
attacks and there's quite a few
countries which are involved in marvel
writing already so Malvar which is
actually coming from governments and the
whole notion of Malvar
my government's would have been science
fiction just 15 years ago but it's very
real and it's it's it's it's been
happening well at least since 2003
probably already earlier and there's
quite a few countries involved obviously
the big superpowers all do it so you
know United States
that's your government it's definitely
doing it Russians the Chinese Iran North
Korea also countries like India and
Pakistan are doing it even countries
like well the Netherlands Germany Sweden
and so on are at least indirectly
involved with my way of writing many of
the European examples actually are
around Marvel writing which is done by
law enforcement
instead of intelligence agencies so
we're talking about cases where local
law enforcement use these malware to
infect their own citizens and they do it
to investigate crimes and it sounds very
very weird but it actually is just an
extension to the rights law enforcement
has always had no rights to listen to
your phone call for example if they
suspect you of a serious enough crime
today we use internet to do everything
anyway so they want to follow what we do
online and they can't get around to our
communications any more by just getting
a wiretap from the local ISP because
very big part of our communication is
encrypted SSL encrypted which means the
operator sees nothing which means if the
cops still want to see what you're doing
they have to get to your computer and
they do that with backdoors and malware
but when we move into the world of
intelligence agencies and militaries
then things change and it's also
interesting to see how the attacks are
different from different countries vast
majority of governmental malware writing
is intelligence gathering so spine it's
about spying and spying is collecting
information and information itself has
changed drastically over the last 20
years I mean the information used to be
this used to be paper so if you wanted
to get this information you had to come
and still this part of paper or copy DS
you had to physically come here well as
you know that's not a problem anymore
because all the information we processed
today is on our computers it's data
which means it can be reached at least
in theory from anywhere in the world
which means spy is no longer have to
come to you in the real world they do it
online so the vast majority of
governmental action is about spying and
that's good too to realize because the
headlines newspapers always label
governmental attacks as cyber war you
know Russian intelligence agencies
hitting American companies and stealing
information it's cyber war well that's
not war at spying spying is not war
spying is spying right the fact that
countries spying it on each other
doesn't mean that they are at war of
course spying is more important when you
are in a war but spying by itself isn't
war and we shouldn't call it war if it
isn't war yes great example great
example of a borderline case obviously
Stuxnet cost damage and it cost physical
damage an attack launched by a country
in another country well right now I
would categorize it as sabotage and the
reason why I'm not calling it a war is
that the United States and Iran were not
at war when it happened if it would have
happened during wartime it would have
clearly been a military strike but
during peacetime I guess the closest we
could call it this cyber sabotage and
Stuxnet is the odd one out because
almost all of these attack that we see
from Western governments our
intelligence operations or or spine
stocks it wasn't spying stocks it was
damaging systems that's the only
destructive attack that we've seen from
your government when we look at
destructive attacks from countries like
North Korea or Iran they are much more
common now
once again attribution becomes
problematic here but for example the
attack against the Sands casinos last
year maybe was done by the Iranians and
it was a very destructive attack they
were wiping thousands of workstations
and servers with their attacks too to
retaliate comments made by the chairman
of the board of Sands casinos against
Iran same thing with the Sony Pictures
attack if it was North Korea well it was
very very destructive not just wiping
servers and workstations but also
stealing massive amount of information
and making it public including stealing
for unreleased Sony Pictures movies and
putting them online for everybody to to
download a couple of examples of recent
stuff that we've been looking at
regarding governmental activity
there's a Verity of malware which we
call Dukes which we believe are all
coming from the Russian government
they're all used to do online espionage
most of them have been active for the
last year and a half in targeting
practically only one country in the
world and that country is Ukraine
because Russia and Ukraine are right now
in the middle of a conflict and of
course in the middle of a conflict of
War espionage becomes even more
important
the targets inside Ukraine include
government offices militaries and
military contractors these variations in
these different tube families but
they're all related we can actually
prove from technical details that they
are coming from from the same parties
now cosmic Duke we started seeing a
little over a year ago and it's it's
also being distributed in emails just
like the old Chinese targeted attacks
it's basically a Windows binary which is
being emailed to the targets and the
targets keep on clicking on the binary
but the targets aren't stupid so why do
they fall for the oldest trick why do
they click on a Windows binary that has
been mailed to them because the attacker
is pretty clever that's basically what
the cosmic do binary looks like when
it's created by the attacker natively
it's a windows screensaver when it comes
out of the compiler that's what it looks
like filed at SCR with the default
windows screensaver icon if I if you
would receive that as an email
attachment you probably wouldn't click
on that but that's not what it looks
like when the attackers actually send it
out the first thing they do is that they
change the icon of the file and don't
ask me why Windows allows you to change
the icon of the screensaver to the icon
of a PDF file but it does and
immediately just by changing the icon
looks more trustworthy then the
attackers renamed the file name from
file that SCR they rename it to this and
that's gibberish it makes no sense and
the reason why it makes no sense is that
if this file name is still missing one
character the first character in the
file name which is an invisible
character it's the Unicode rlo character
right to left over right
the character you use for example to
display Arabic which is written from
right to left and when that invisible
character is added to the file name then
windows will display the file name from
right to left and the file name becomes
RCS that Ukraine gas pipelines security
report March 2014 dot PDF dot PDF
it's not a PDF file it's actually a
screensaver it's an SCR file which you
can tell because the file names start
with RCS which is reversed SCR but you
would click on this if you receive this
attachment in an email from someone you
know and trust
you will click on it and yes there will
be an extra prompt from Windows when you
click on an exe or a screensaver instead
of clicking a PDF but but you just just
click OK I just click OK to make the box
go away that's what they do
so that's cosmic Duke then we found
onion Duke last year which is
interesting in the way it replicates
itself we found rogue onion routers
online you know the Tuerto routing
system which is used by by thousands and
thousands of people to reroute their
internet traffic
we found rogue nodes which worked just
like all the other nodes except every
time you download it a binary it would
infect it on the fly so if you were
downloading windows binaries over HTTP
instead of HTTP if you were using HTTP
and download it
any Exe file you would get an infected
file instead which means many automatic
update systems which download updates in
the background and update applications
on their own would actually
automatically infect your system you
wouldn't even have to do anything if
they were using HTTP instead of HTTP
which of course they shouldn't but
surprisingly many did so this was
Russian government running rogue nodes
to infect downloads over to Tor network
we don't exactly know who they were
targeting with this but they were doing
this and then this morning we released a
paper on cozy Duke which is the latest
in this in this series of Mulder coming
from the Russian government
we actually have a white paper out on
this in our block if you're interested
in details on this particular case but
I'll just highlight one feature in it
which is the way they do command and
control because these are all bots they
all need control it has to be a server
somewhere through which the attackers
can control the infected machines or can
for example steal data from there so
they have somehow have to connect back
to the to the masterminds or back to the
spies traditional way of doing this is
just having a static domain name and
server running at the domain name but
it's fairly easy to shutdown domain
names like that or even better take them
over and run run it as a honeypot which
gives you then information about who's
infected which we've done it several
times and it works like a charm
so the attackers have been trying to
figure out new alternative ways of
controlling doing the component control
so it couldn't be taken over or it
couldn't be shut down in this particular
case they decided to use Twitter so this
is from the configuration file of Cody
Duke it actually names a Twitter account
called us two five one five and then it
sets these special the limiters that is
being used to mark tweets which then
become commands for the botnet and that
account us two five one five is actually
live on Twitter right now we're still
running this morning when I checked a
couple of hours ago account called
another researcher with the avatar being
a picture of a monkey running on a bear
don't ask me why and it follows one
account one account owned in that
account is called monkey drive another
reference to monkeys and that account
actually had two tweets which matched
the format at this particular Trojan is
looking for the latest tweet is from
February 27th so that's less than two
months ago and this monkey reference is
keep on coming one of the ways they have
actually been distributing cozy Duke is
through emails which link the user into
a video about monkeys in an office so we
don't really know what the significance
of this is but it is clearly linked back
to the same operations which we believe
are coming from the Russian government
and this Cody Duke is the malware which
hit White House in October so it's
Russian actors trying to gain access to
US government systems and I actually
tried looking at the White House
computer systems a little bit about like
what kind of computers are are they
actually using in the White House so I
was looking at open source like pictures
from White House seems to be it's mostly
running Windows based systems some
screenshots would indicate Windows 7
actually that's the famous picture of
from the White House Situation Room as
they're following the bin Laden takedown
those are HP laptops and that seems to
be a Dell laptop used by President Obama
then we have other kinds of governmental
activity this is a photo from a door
which had a make a quick hack note put
in there by IT admins to warn people who
were coming to the office that please do
not log into your computer and please
don't use internet imagine coming to
work and seeing that at your door for
almost any organization today that means
that today you will do no work no
computers no internet what what do you
do I don't know I wouldn't do much
anything at all if I wouldn't have a
computer and an internet connection and
of course this is from the door of Sony
Pictures last December the attack
against Sony Pictures was like I said
remarkably aggressive
and of course the US government very
quickly pointed out that is this attack
they believe is coming from North Korea
and we had really hard time believing
the story initially that you know it's a
retaliation from a foreign government to
revenge a movie which makes fun and
actually assassinates their dictator but
US government kept on repeating that
that's that's what's going on it's the
North Koreans and they know but they
can't tell how
they know and then when I was looking at
Sony's history of course Sony has had a
long history with security problems not
just getting dust over and over again
but also Sony shipping route kids to
their users on their music CDs and all
kinds of weird stuff there's an there
was an interview with the Sony Pictures
cio around four years ago in which he
made comments about how his most
important job has to see you I always to
make sure they don't over invest into
things like cybersecurity and he gave an
example that you know if there's a
legacy database which is not secure and
securing the database would cost you ten
million dollars but the damage done by
the database getting leaked would only
be 1 million dollars then it makes no
sense to security which sort of makes
sense well I think today he would
probably have a different opinion about
this after what happened then again it
doesn't matter anymore because he is no
longer the CIO of Sony Pictures then New
York Times ran the story in early
February where they told the world how
the US government knew that it was the
North Koreans they knew because they had
hacked the North Korean networks already
four years earlier so now the story
changes from damn North Koreans hacking
our companies here in United States to
damned North Koreans hacking our
companies and we know because we hacked
them four years ago what about then the
attacks coming from you guys from US
government what do your victims look
like well they look like him this is
Professor John Jack Kika tear from the
technical university of brussels I
believe professor of cryptographic he
was infected by your government around a
year and a half ago why we don't really
know maybe it has something to do with
his work which is mostly around
cryptography Susan like recovering from
catastrophic failures of cryptographic
all systems and things like that or
another example of victims of your
government this is a leaf arrays he's a
suicide me for a German car
my company called stiller actually have
a short video here filmed by their
Spiegel let me play it in this video
der Spiegel journalist take some Snowden
leaks and shows them to these engineers
who all work for this company still
Erick still Larry said is a nice P
specializing in satellite communications
and these guys see for the first time
that their company actually has been
hacked and they just realized that
foreign government in this case UK and
US government's have hacked into their
networks and then they see names of
workstation that I have been hacked and
they see their own names they just
realized that their own systems their
personal machines have been hacked
which is remarkable and these guys are
see that means they're not terrorists
they're not criminals there are bad
people the regular normal engineers and
they get targeted not because of what
they do themselves but because they can
be used as a vector to gain access to
where the attackers want to get in this
case these guys provide connectivity to
well satellite internet connectivity is
used especially in Central Africa in
Middle East in Afghanistan you can see
why intelligence agencies would be
interested in gaining access to the core
routers of a company like this but these
guys end up being the victims in all of
these without with no fault of their own
last example there was a scientific
conference in Houston three years ago
after the conference the attendees at
least some of the attendees received the
cd-rom from the organizers with the
pictures from the conference and those
theorems did not come from the
organizers they were launched once again
we believe by your government and the
altar run on the cd-rom executed this
photo viewing application which showed
you the photo from the conference and
the photos were really from the
conference but the application showing
the photos actually was back toward with
a two-record double fantasy
which is coming from your government
then we have the Chinese they're still
at it as they've been throughout all the
years I'll give you one example of the
kind of espionage toolkits they run and
that's Madren the matter is interesting
because it's written in Lisp piece of
malware written in Lisp we very very
rarely see mildly written in Lisp but
this one is written in Lisp which is
kind of cool
the reason why it's written in Lisp is
that least still today is the macro
language inside AutoCAD and AutoCAD is
being used by engineering houses all
over the world to do drawings technical
drawings drawings of buildings or
devices or whatever and what made the
does is that it infected these drawings
the actual drawings themselves become
infected and then when engineering
houses give those drawings to their
customers or exchanged them with other
engineering houses their alter cats
become infected and as they open other
files they become infected as well so
eventually all of their drawings are
infected and as they keep exchanging
them with other engineering houses it
spreads from one company to another from
one country to another and this has
become a global problem and of course it
doesn't just infect the files it also
sends I don't know a backup copy to an
email address in mainland China so they
gather a remarkable collection of
technical drawings from all kinds of
engineering houses all over the world
with this particular attack another
example in this case mobile malware
written by a government would be what
happened late last year in Hong Kong you
remember the protests that were going on
for weeks in Hong Kong where people were
demanding freedom of speech these
protests were organized by several local
freedom of speech organizations and they
were of course organized over the
Internet and our smartphones here's a
whatsapp message sent by the organizers
which has a link to an application you
could actually download and install to
your iPhone or Android with
then you could use it to communicate
with the other protesters and get
information about activities the only
problem was that this whatsapp message
was not sent by the organizers this was
sent from mainland China
it was spoofed to look like a real
message from the organizers but it
wasn't and the application that you got
when you followed the link was a real
application which really did allow you
to communicate with the other protesters
and see information about the protests
but it also collected your address book
and send it to mainland China and it
also collected your location with GPS
and Center to mainland China so here's
an example of mobile malware written by
our government and two weeks ago we were
all following the massive attack against
github the attack was done with the
Great Firewall of China basically
turning it around Great Firewall of
China has originally been built to
filter traffic coming out of China to
block websites or pages that they don't
like for one reason or another in this
particular case they turn it around when
people from outside of China visited
Chinese web websites the Great Firewall
would inject an extra Chaves crypt into
your browser and that would cause your
browser to run this script which would
then cause your browser to generate
massive amount of traffic to against
github in particular against two pages
under github or one of them is called
great fire one of them is called CNN New
York Times and great fire is an
organization which provides information
on how to bypass the Great Firewall of
China how to run VPNs how to run tor how
to run your own proxies which is
obviously information that the Great
Firewall itself would try to filter the
main web site of great fire is called
Great Fire of org and that has been
filtered by the Chinese for years but
now they were hosting their information
in addition of their own website under
github and now this became a problem for
the Chinese government because they
wanted to filter that information
they didn't want people to go and read
that information however github org runs
under SSL they have no HTTP version of
the site every page is HTTPS which means
when this traffic coming in coming out
from China and passes through the Great
Firewall they don't know which page
under github that org you're going to
they just see that you're going to
github the dog which means they cannot
filter out just these pages under grid
under github the dog they either have to
filter out the whole site or nothing
they can't select individual pages to be
filtered so what do you do if you want
to filter or what I get rid of
information and you can't filter it and
then they can't filter all of github the
dog because Chinese companies I actually
checked guava has 32 open source
projects which are run from github to
talk Xiaomi I think 16 open source
projects under some Chinese companies
need github they cannot filter out
github the dog just cannot be done so
what they were trying to do here is
bullying they're trying to bully github
the org to removing the offensive
content themselves they create massive
attack very costly and painful attack
fork it up and keep it up and the github
admins know that if they would just get
rid of those two pages the attack would
stop and this is bullying and we all
learned something about bullying already
when we were kids in school there was
always the big boy in the class who was
bullying others and you knew that if you
give in to bullying it just gets worse
so we shouldn't give in to bullying not
even when the attacker is big and strong
this particular attack against github is
highly unusual the way it was created
the way it was run completely out of
completely extraordinary most of the
attacks we see online are
much more mundane typically most of them
are actually bought bought from services
that specialize in launching attacks for
example IPS stress test which is one of
these sites that we we can easily find
which are just telling attacks let me
actually play you a an ad video that
they use to advertise their attack
services
nice video almost makes me feel like
going to buy a DDoS attack no I don't
recommend anybody to use their services
but I think it's a good example and just
how shameless many of these operators
are it's easy to fly these attacks
privately cheap to buy for an attack
like let's say an hour of keeping
another website down you would pay five
to ten dollars so very affordable of
course they can't it depends on on the
size of the site you really need to take
down but obviously any site can always
be dosed if you just can generate enough
traffic it can happen we saw a very good
example of that during Christmas period
when Sony PlayStation Network which has
140 million users was taken down by the
way with the botnet which was running on
top of DSL boxes so the botnet that cost
the amount of traffic for Xbox Live and
PlayStation Network that what net wasn't
infected computers it was infected DSL
modems so we're getting closer back to
what we were discussing about they
infected Internet of Things that
connected devices launching an attack of
that scale so what's the biggest lie on
the Internet
what's the biggest line and why do all
do all the time it is I have read and I
agree to the License Agreement and you
know it's true you keep making this line
every time you sign up to a new service
every time you install an app every time
you install an application and we know
that people lying we know because we
tried this we actually set up a free
Wi-Fi hotspot in London late last year
and in the License Agreement for the
free Wi-Fi in the summer in the center
of all the legalese we had a small
segment about your firstborn child where
we would take your kid and keep it or if
you don't have children we would take
your most beloved pet
and everybody clicked okay everybody of
course clicked okay and this is how we
keep signing away our rights because we
really have only two problems to solve
if you want to keep this internet thing
going we have to solve the problems of
security but also the problems of
privacy our security is mostly being
threatened by criminals but our privacy
is mostly being threatened by companies
by businesses who break no laws when
they threaten our privacy because we
give them the right we sign away our
rights we accept we have read and we
agree with your terms and conditions
it's especially bad when you look at
mobile apps we all know that all the app
stores and Google plays are filled with
hundreds of thousands of free apps free
apps free well there is no free lunch
and there are no free apps and there are
no free search engines and there are no
free cloud storages they don't exist
there are a couple of things online
which are really and truly free you know
Linux kernel that's free and open all
right I'll give you that
but almost everything that's labeled as
free online today really isn't free and
it's quite frustrating actually that we
ended up into the situation where users
automatically assume that all the
services online are created you don't
have to pay for them this wasn't obvious
20 years ago when when the Weber's young
it could have turned out to something
else I remember very well when I was
setting up our first web site in our
first web server httpd server in 1994
and we set up our first web site and we
got a couple of visitors in exciting and
we realize that this is couldn't become
a big thing this web thing is going to
become huge because it's so easy to use
you know just click on links and see
pictures and everything
excellent and then we had a disc
with a couple of the guys in the lab
about what what does it mean well it
will mean that eventually there's going
to be lots of content online content
like I don't know news or weather
reports maybe even entertainment maybe
even videos maybe books things like
these will happen but then we were
confused about okay if that's gonna
happen if you're gonna get all this
content online how are we going to pay
for the content and we ain't got no idea
but we assumed that the browser's would
integrate some sort of a payment system
and there would be a button to pay for
the content like I want to read that
news article and I click the button to
pay I don't know a cent for an article
or I want to read today's Dilbert for
half a cent click something like that
that's what we assumed well we were
wrong 20 years later we still don't have
a way of paying for content online
instead it's completely alternative way
of paying for content appeared which is
profiling the users and selling that
information to advertisers that's how
Google works that's how Facebook works
that's how all the free services work
and this is it's remarkable when you
look at how the monetization works like
you install it's the simplest ad you can
imagine like a flashlight app for your
smartphone and then you look at the
rights it requests from you including
the right to see your location and to
access your mails and to send all that
information now they have to monetize
somehow right so collecting your
information and selling it out works and
I was frankly a little bit surprised
when I was looking at just how
effectively for example Twitter allows
the profiling of its users like if you
actually go it's very enlightening when
you go to these services like Google or
Facebook or Twitter not as a user but as
a customer as a paying customer you go
there and you buy an ad because then you
see just how how well you can target the
ads
so for example you go to Twitter and you
want to promote a tweet you want to get
one single tweet shown to other people
so it lets you to you know target your
campaign target your tweet campaign and
you can do basic stuff like you know
time of day when this tweet is going to
be shown to people and you actually pay
for this tweet to be shown or location
San Jose ten mile radius of San Jose or
you can select you know what kind of
device the user are using like only show
this to iPhone users for example that's
pretty basic you would expect that but
then the targeting gets more specific so
for example you can only show your tweet
to people with different interests like
you know people are interested in
minivans right that's already a little
bit weird like how does Twitter know
who's interested in minimize or off-road
vehicles but it gets worse because then
you can do things like this let's target
serial buyers and you can choose whether
you want to show your tweet to people
who buy Kellogg's Frosted Flakes or
Kellogg's Rice Krispie really now that's
interesting what about then targeting
alcohol buyers people who buy hard
liquor and it will tell you that it's
1.6 3 million people like this that this
could be shown your tweet could be shown
and of course you can combine these so
let's show my tweet to hard liquor
buyers who like minivans and live in San
Jose and it will tell you exactly how
many people there are like that and it
will show your tweet to them as long as
you pay or income how much money you're
making you want to show it to rich
people no problem there's five hundred
and fifty one thousand Twitter users who
whose household income is more than
hundred thousand dollars a year or
people who have lately been wet or
people or families which are expecting
right now there's 1.6 2 million Twitter
users who are expecting a baby right now
and now it gets weird like how does
Twitter know this
they really do know they do know this is
no joke
this will work and the trick here is a
small part provided by CPG or axiom or a
bunch of other data brokers so this
information is not based on your tweets
there's nothing to do with your tweets
this is information is based on
information that these data brokers
collect from the real world for example
by buying the information from frequent
pilot programs here in the real world
and then they combine your information
like for example your buying habits to
your Twitter account and they do the
connection with your mobile phone number
you have to register with your mobile
phone number and they know that this guy
who buys hard liquor with this credit
card has this phone number and it's the
same phone number as this Twitter
account they know which you so you know
you could easily create an ad campaign
which only shows your ads to families
which are expecting a kid and are buying
a lot of hard liquor which probably
would be the majority of them it's
pretty stressful I don't know how well
this actually is checked of course you
can engage the system easy if you know
how it works I suppose most people have
no idea
and of course they could also connect
you to this data with your email address
or even with your street address
although I don't think Twitter asked for
spreaders they do ask for your email on
your mobile phone number and that's
enough to link you back and it is a bit
sad to realize that the best minds in
the world are spending their effort into
delivering of ads and in the profiling
of us Internet user the great minds in
work in companies right here in Silicon
Valley who could be doing something
important and instead they are focused
on delivering ads which is a bit sad
it's great to get all these free
services but frankly
I'd rather pay money for these services
if they then wouldn't profile me but I
don't have it information - yeah of
course if I'd rather pay money if I
would then know that they wouldn't
profile me how do you know there's
anybody down arithmetic as to how much
would actually cost to do a search on
Google if I paid for it well we local 8
Google's monetization and look at it the
other way around
Google's profit last year was 12 billion
dollars if we make a modest assumption
that they had 1 billion users that means
that you make them $12 profit last year
so did you so did you so did Nick well
he didn't make $12 then you have to make
$24 Google's income goes to running the
ad infrastructure as compared to
actually doing the search
it's hard to separate the ad
infrastructure from everything else we
do know how much money Google puts into
data centers and that's roughly 2
billion dollars a quarter 2 billion
dollars a quarter which is remarkable a
company which products are free where
users pay no money for the products a
company invests 2 billion dollars a
quarter just into their data centers and
they yet they're still profitable so
it's it's one of those things that we
could have never ever guessed 20 years
ago when whoever's young this could
actually happen but it did it's
remarkable so it's been a pretty wild
ride from the early days of virus is
spreading on floppy disks written by
happy hackers for fun into the world of
organized online crime and into the
world of governmental malware writing
but like I said we only have to solve
the problems of security and privacy and
we were the first generation that got
online we all received a free and open
Internet and now it's up to us to decide
what kind of an Internet
are we leaving for the next generation
thank you very much
you